Jason, I know we got to do the show, but do you have something else that you need to do? I just did not get up early enough to take care of everything one usually takes care of in the morning. Like taking out the trash or whatever? Well, some people call it that. Like opening some windows? All right, so we'll pause. Why don't you take care of that and then we'll just play the music and stuff and then we'll
Jason，我知道我们得录节目，但你还有别的事要忙吗？我早上起得不够早，没能处理完平时早上该处理的事。比如倒垃圾之类的？嗯，有些人是这么叫的。比如开开窗户？好吧，那我们暂停一下。你先去忙那个，然后我们放点音乐什么的，接着我们就
be at All New SmartList. No, let's just make this a fast episode. No, let's just go to all new Smartless. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
开始全新的SmartLess。不，我们还是快点录完这一集吧。不，我们直接开始全新的SmartLess。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
Less。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。
Will, did you just finish a workout? You got a little bit of sweat going there on the front of the shirt. I did. I didn't even have, I haven't showered. I just put on a clean shirt. I haven't showered yet. Luckily I'm in my booth, but I know it's gross. What's the flavor of workout currently?
Will，你刚锻炼完吗？你衬衫前面有点汗。是的。我甚至还没洗澡。我只是换了一件干净的衬衫。我还没洗澡呢。幸好我在录音棚里，但我知道这很恶心。最近在做什么运动？
Are you still doing the nonsense with the platinum white leather punching bag? No, I'm not boxing or anything. It's really, by the way, a great workout with my friends over at Fight Camp. But no, I'm now in, I'm now boxing or anybody's really that by the way a great workout with my friends over at fight camp But no, I'm I'm now in I'm now doing the catalyst. I'm in the the catalyst suit Electra electric pulses. Yeah. Oh, I get it Oh, this is the big lazy loser workout where you just put zip on a suit that electro shocks you and you don't need to do shit You can just sleep there. I'm doing a workout while I do it and it's a great product.
你还在玩那个白金白皮拳击袋的无聊把戏吗？不，我没在练拳击什么的。顺便说一下，我和Fight Camp的朋友们一起练那个真的很棒。但不是，我现在在……我现在在练Catalyst。我穿着Catalyst套装，有电脉冲。噢，我明白了。噢，这就是那种大懒汉运动，你只要穿上一套会电击你的衣服，什么都不用做，躺在那儿就行了。我做的时候也在运动，这产品真的很棒。
Jason, he looks like, when he wears it, he looks like Beyonce from the Single Ladies video. Okay, well thanks for the reference from 2008. We really appreciate it. Listen. And I'd appreciate if you stop, don't stop talking to me like I can recall Beyonce videos at the drop of a hat,
Jason，他穿上那身衣服的时候，看起来就像《Single Ladies》MV里的碧昂丝。好吧，谢谢你引用2008年的梗。我们真的很感激。听着，我希望你别再用那种好像我随口就能想起碧昂丝MV的语气跟我说话了，
because I can't. Yeah, but by the way, her album just came out. It's really good. Okay, yeah, it is the country one. Is it good? You've heard it? It's really good, yeah, it's really, really good. Is it real twangy country, like real?
因为我根本想不起来。是啊，不过顺便说一下，她的新专辑刚出。真的很不错。好吧，是那张乡村音乐专辑吗？好听吗？你听过了？真的很好听，非常非常棒。是那种真正的乡村音乐，很有那种韵味吗？
No, it's just her version of it, yeah? She's got a lot of collaborations on it. You know who did a great country album is Beck. You remember Beck's country album? Oh yeah. It was very good. Yeah, yeah. Well, we'll just send that to the notes.
不，那是她自己的版本，对吧？她里面有很多合作曲目。你知道谁出过很棒的乡村专辑吗？是Beck。你记得Beck的乡村专辑吗？噢，记得。非常棒。是啊，是啊。好吧，我们把这个记在笔记里。
Hang on, hang on. 1990s calling. What are we? Sorry. By the way, Sean, doesn't JB look like he could put out a country record right now? Absolutely. Yeah.
等等，等等。20世纪90年代来电话了。我们这是在干嘛？抱歉。顺便问一下，Sean，JB看起来是不是随时都能出一张乡村唱片？绝对是。是啊。
No, and then you just tilt down and you see that. Oh, look at the pixies. It's like he's got the pixies on. Name one pixie song. The Night We Went Out. There we go. I mean, this is great. He's got the pixies on. Name one pixie song. The Night We Went Out. There we go. I mean this is great. Is that a real song?
不，然后你往下看，你就看到了那个。噢，看那些小精灵（Pixies）。他好像穿了小精灵乐队的衣服。说出一首小精灵乐队的歌。The Night We Went Out。这就对了。我是说，这太棒了。他穿了小精灵乐队的衣服。说出一首小精灵乐队的歌。The Night We Went Out。这就对了。我是说这太棒了。那真的是首歌吗？
Is that a real song? It's just a great t-shirt. Let's get to our guests. Another guest that I have, listen, this damn project I'm working on here on the East Coast is really cutting into my prep time for my guests. And so I have not yet been able to write an intro
那真的是首歌吗？这只是一件很棒的T恤。我们来介绍嘉宾吧。我还有另一位嘉宾，听着，我在东海岸做的这个该死的项目真的占用了我准备嘉宾介绍的时间。所以自从这个项目开始以来，我还没能写出
for my guests since this project has been in existence. However, yeah, well, it just puts me on par with you guys. How many, it's always somebody else or something else's fault. When's it your fault? Never, okay, never. So I'm not just gonna just say his name. I will say,
嘉宾的介绍词。不过，好吧，这让我和你们处于同一水平了。有多少次，总是别人的错或者别的事的错。什么时候才是你的错？从来没有，好吧，从来没有。所以我不会只说他的名字。我会说，
I am happy to have this gentleman here. This is like the worst intro ever. I love him, he is a dear friend of mine, and yours, Will. Sean, I think you may know him, I'm not sure. But listen, this is the kind of guy that has got so much kindness and warmth in him that you actually, if you're a cynic like me,
我很高兴这位先生能来。这简直是有史以来最烂的介绍。我爱他，他是我的挚友，也是你的，Will。Sean，我想你可能认识他，我不确定。但听着，这家伙身上有那么多的善良和温暖，如果你像我一样是个愤世嫉俗的人，
you doubt his sincerity. But if you know him as well as I do, you know it's sincere. Kang, this is somebody who is absolute royalty in our business. He is one of my favorite people in the world. He's one of our best actors, one of our best comics, an incredible author.
你甚至会怀疑他的真诚。但如果你像我一样了解他，你就知道他是真诚的。Kang，这是我们这一行绝对的泰斗。他是我世界上最喜欢的人之一。他是我们最好的演员之一，最好的喜剧演员之一，一位了不起的作家。
You can't say enough. Just come on out. Everybody, it's Henry Winkler. Ah, I love Henry Winkler. Are you, I mean, what can you say? Are you joking? I can bow for the sincerest sincerity thing. How do you?
怎么夸都不为过。快出来吧。各位，他就是Henry Winkler。啊，我爱Henry Winkler。你是说，我还能说什么呢？你在开玩笑吗？我可以为那种最真诚的真诚作证。你怎么……
You're like dubbed the nicest person in show business. Exactly. Yeah, but you know what? I don't necessarily think I am the nicest. I think I'm just grateful. Yeah, oh, grateful. I love that. I'm just grateful.
你被誉为演艺圈最友善的人。没错。是啊，但你知道吗？我不一定觉得我是最友善的。我觉得我只是心怀感激。是啊，噢，感激。我喜欢这个。我只是心怀感激。
And I sometimes I'm so filled with just being on the earth. Yeah. No, you can feel it. You know what, I believe you, Henry. I do, I believe you. I've spent some time, I really believe you. It's so good to see you. Thank you, I'm so happy to finally be on the show.
有时我只是因为活在这个世界上而感到无比充实。是啊。不，你能感觉得到。你知道吗，Henry，我相信你。真的，我相信你。我花了一些时间，我真的相信你。见到你真好。谢谢，我很高兴终于能上这个节目了。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Now look at the desk behind you, my God, that's a pile of work you got going on in your desk. That's one of the greatest offices you'll ever step into. The wall that he's facing right now is stock-filled with stuff you could spend an hour looking at, all these memories, all these tchotchkes and memorabilia and, right?
是啊，是啊，是啊。现在看看你身后的桌子，天哪，你桌子上堆了那么多东西。那是我见过最棒的办公室之一。他现在面对的那面墙上堆满了东西，你可以花一个小时去看，所有的这些回忆，所有的这些小摆件和纪念品，对吧？
It's true, it's true, but remember, I've been doing this a long time. Yeah. You know, what I didn't know is that this was only a voice podcast that we weren't recording it video. I could have been in my pajamas. Yeah, like us.
是真的，是真的，但记住，我做这一行很久了。是啊。你知道，我不知道这只是个语音播客，我们没在录视频。我本来可以穿睡衣的。是啊，像我们一样。
Yeah, like us. Or in a sweaty, sweaty t-shirt like me. Yeah. And you could have taken your hair off even, Henry. Not a lot of people know that Henry has been bald since 14. Um. 14 years old. Yeah, unfortunately, yeah.
是啊，像我们一样。或者像我一样穿着汗湿的T恤。是啊。Henry，你甚至可以把头发摘下来。没多少人知道Henry从14岁起就秃了。嗯。14岁。是啊，不幸的是，是的。
But, uh. I used to do the limbo at high school dances, you know? It was the only way I got some self-esteem and the wig slid right off. No way. Oh, it was horrible. Because of your skills. Imagine thinking, imagine thinking, I got low self-esteem,
但是，呃。我以前在高中舞会上跳凌波舞，你知道吗？这是我获得自尊的唯一方式，然后假发就滑下来了。不会吧。噢，太可怕了。因为你的技巧。想象一下，想象一下，我自尊心很低，
how am I gonna build it up? You know what I'm gonna do? I'm gonna answer the limbo. Limbo the shit out of this party. I was the best in my high school. Is that true? I'll bet. Yeah. You know why I believe that, Henry,
我该怎么建立它呢？你知道我要做什么吗？我要去跳凌波舞。我要在这场派对上大跳凌波舞。我是我们高中跳得最好的。是真的吗？我敢打赌。是啊。你知道为什么我相信这一点，Henry，
is because I'm now, what just came to mind was that episode of Happy Days, where you do, where the Fonz does that dance The kuzatski. Yeah, will you get low? Yeah so My parents took me to see the musae of folk ballet at Madison Square Garden when I was in the sixth grade And this is that athletic jumping in the air,
是因为我现在，脑子里突然想起了《欢乐时光》（Happy Days）的那一集，你跳了，Fonz跳了那个舞蹈，哥萨克舞（kuzatski）。是啊，你蹲得很低？是啊，所以我父母在我六年级的时候带我去看麦迪逊广场花园的民间芭蕾舞表演。那是那种在空中跳跃的运动，
spread eagle doing the ba ba ba ba. And I was overwhelmed and taught myself a bastardized version in my room that I would do at any dance I attended. Really? And that was your closer, right? That was my closer. So how did it come about that you're making happy days
双腿张开做着“吧吧吧吧”。我被震撼了，就在房间里自学了一个拙劣的版本，我参加的任何舞会都会跳。真的吗？那是你的压轴戏，对吧？那是我的压轴戏。那么你是怎么在拍《欢乐时光》的时候，
and did they say, Fonz needs to have it? And you're like, hang on a second, I got this. I got this in my back pocket. Do you know, interestingly enough, I would ask, there were so many episodes, I was asked to do all kinds of stuff. And they came up with this, how do you win the dance contest?
他们说，Fonz需要跳这个吗？然后你说，等一下，我有这个。我口袋里有这个。你知道，有趣的是，我会问，有那么多集，我被要求做各种各样的事情。他们想出了这个，你怎么赢得舞蹈比赛？
And I said, well, I can do this. And they played Havana-Gila and I was off and running. Right? Right? Right? Is that? Was it, was it, was it, we're gonna pop around all over the place, but while we're there,
我说，好吧，我可以跳这个。他们放了《Havana-Gila》，我就开始跳了。对吧？对吧？对吧？是吗？是……是……我们要到处聊聊，但既然聊到这儿了，
I mean, was it, the Fonz was not meant to be the star of the show, correct? No, I had six lines. When I auditioned, I had six lines, and then I worked one day a week for the first year. And being anxious and short, I could not leave my apartment on a weekday, so I just sat in my apartment waiting for the day of work
我是说，Fonz本来不是要当主角的，对吧？不，我只有六句台词。我试镜的时候，只有六句台词，然后第一年我每周只工作一天。因为焦虑和个子矮，我在工作日不敢离开公寓，所以我只是坐在公寓里等着工作日，
and then waiting for the weekend when I could finally leave. Wow, what do you mean you were afraid to leave your apartment because you're anxious and short? No, I wasn't afraid. I couldn't leave my apartment because I was so duty bound, I couldn't play on a work day. Oh, gotcha. So I had all the fan mail delivered to my apartment
然后等着周末，我终于可以出门了。哇，你说你不敢离开公寓是因为你焦虑和个子矮是什么意思？不，我不是害怕。我不能离开公寓是因为我太有责任感了，我不能在工作日玩。噢，明白了。所以我所有的粉丝来信都寄到了我的公寓，
and so it was pretty much like a hoarder navigating my way through the boxes of letters in crayon. I'm written directly to your address? Like you just gave out your address? No, no, no, it came to Paramount and Paramount had it delivered. All right, got it, good. And then I would get presents, you know?
所以那里简直就像个囤积狂的窝，我在蜡笔写的信箱里穿行。是直接寄到你的地址吗？就像你直接给出了你的地址？不，不，不，是寄到派拉蒙影业，然后派拉蒙派人送来的。好吧，明白了，很好。然后我会收到礼物，你知道吗？
Sure, sure. I got a metal cutting that said, if you will it, it is not a dream, which became my watchword, or my phrase for the rest of my life. Your mantra. If you will it, you can have what it is you want. I believe that, 100%.
当然，当然。我收到一个金属切割件，上面写着：如果你有意志，它就不是梦，这成了我的座右铭，或者说我余生的口头禅。你的咒语。如果你有意志，你就能得到你想要的。我100%相信这一点。
And that came on a what? Like somebody asked you to? On a metal cutting that was sent to me in the mail by a fan. So it was out of the license plate shop at the prison, right? You know what? It could have been. It's just a spare license plate.
那是怎么来的？就像有人让你……是在监狱里的车牌店里做的金属切割件，寄给我的，是一个粉丝寄的。所以，你知道吗？很有可能。那只是个多余的车牌。
It could have been. And then I had it framed. Sure. So I have, and it's up on my wall in... That's pretty cool. I like the idea that somebody does that, that somebody like, some guy, Jason's joking about he's in prison,
很有可能。然后我把它装裱起来了。当然。所以我把它挂在我的墙上……那太酷了。我喜欢有人这样做的主意，有人，Jason在开玩笑说他在监狱里，
but some dude who's a big fan, he had a few too many pops one night and just etched it into a metal frame as a nothing, and for you it became your mantra. It became my mantra. Put it on metal as a bit of a clutterbuster. He doesn't want to get caught up in all the other fan letters. Well, I got a lot of wood, too.
但某个大粉丝，那天晚上喝多了，随手把它刻在金属框上，对他来说没什么，但对你来说它成了你的咒语。它成了我的咒语。把它放在金属上，算是一种杂物清理。他不想被其他粉丝来信困住。好吧，我也有很多木头。
Sure, I'll bet. Sure. A lot of wood. Jewelry, little girls would send me their bears or their crucifixes. And I'll bet the big girl sent some lingerie. I mean, the font was a bit of a sex symbol. Yes, and then people would come to the apartment and lift their shirt and ask me to sign parts of their anatomy. No way. Oh, I got it. And of course I wouldn't because I was afraid
当然，我敢打赌。当然。很多木头。珠宝，小女孩会寄给我她们的熊或十字架。我敢打赌大女孩会寄一些内衣。我是说，Fonz是个性象征。是的，然后人们会来到公寓，掀起衬衫，让我给她们身体的某些部位签名。不会吧。噢，我明白了。当然我不会，因为我怕
that the ink would get into their bloodstream. Yeah, good for you. What a nice guy. That would be the first time I would doubt your sincerity, right there. Yeah, you can if you want. Sure, so people can show up now, your house tarps off, no problem.
墨水会进入她们的血液。是啊，为你点赞。真是个好人。那将是我第一次怀疑你的真诚，就在那一刻。是啊，如果你想怀疑的话可以。当然，所以人们现在可以出现了，你脱掉上衣，没问题。
Yeah. No fear of getting any ink. Oh, oh, oh. I shouldn't have... Well, okay. So I'm sitting in my apartment. I have a Victrola, because everything was vinyl. I went to Tower Records on Sunset Boulevard.
是啊。不用担心沾上墨水。噢，噢，噢。我不该……好吧，好吧。所以我坐在公寓里。我有一个留声机，因为那时候都是黑胶唱片。我去了日落大道的Tower Records。
I bought Dan Fogelberg, and I was listening to Dan Fogelberg on my rented Victrola. The door knocks, I get up, there are three men with badges, and I said, oh no, you do not smell what you think you're smelling, oh my God. There was some weird door. And they said, we're with the FBI. We're not here for that.
我买了Dan Fogelberg的唱片，我在租来的留声机上听Dan Fogelberg。有人敲门，我起来，有三个戴着徽章的人，我说，噢不，你们闻到的不是你们想的那种味道，噢天哪。门外有些奇怪。他们说，我们是FBI的。我们不是为了那个来的。
We just wanted to meet the Fonz. No way. No way. Wow. That's pretty cool. That's so funny. That's a bit of an abuse of their assets, right? I was so happy that I was not being put in handcuffs. I didn't care what they did Yeah, they're all paranoid. Oh, you're so you're right. You're so happy that you're not getting busted for having a big pile of stinky bud
我们只是想见见Fonz。不会吧。不会吧。哇。那太酷了。太搞笑了。那有点滥用职权了，对吧？我太高兴我没被戴上手铐了。我不在乎他们做了什么。是啊，他们都多疑。噢，你是对的。你太高兴你没因为有一大堆臭烘烘的草而被抓了。
Hey Henry, let me ask you this I remember you telling me years ago the story about when you got that part unhappy I didn't know we're just in the happy days era right now because it it was such a huge part of a, you know, culturally, I don't think people understand how big it was if you're younger, starting the late 70s into the 80s, how massive Happy Days was globally. You got that part, I think you told me once,
嘿Henry，让我问你这个。我记得多年前你告诉我你得到《欢乐时光》那个角色的故事。我不知道我们现在正处于《欢乐时光》时代，因为它在文化上太重要了，如果你年轻的话，我不认为人们理解它有多大，从70年代末到80年代，《欢乐时光》在全球有多么巨大。你得到了那个角色，我想你曾经告诉过我，
but will you remind me of that story of how that came to be? I was not a complete human being in my life. I could not connect my mind and my emotion. I was just being who I thought I should be. Why? I come from, walking into my apartment was like walking into a minefield. My short German parents were horrible.
但你能提醒我那个故事是怎么发生的吗？我当时不是一个完整的人。我无法连接我的思想和情感。我只是在扮演我以为我应该扮演的人。为什么？我来自……走进我的公寓就像走进雷区。我矮小的德国父母太可怕了。
But I... Oh wait, go back, what? Hey. We'll go back on that. I could somehow unleash myself professionally. So I walk in to the audition, and I changed my voice. I said, hi, my name is Henry, I'm from New York City,
但我……噢等等，回去，什么？嘿。我们回头再说那个。我不知怎么地能在职业上释放自己。所以我走进试镜室，我改变了我的声音。我说，嗨，我叫Henry，我来自纽约市，
and I'm here to try out for the part of Fonzie, or the Fonzarelli. And then I looked at the guy who was reading with me, his name was Pasquale. And I don't know where it came from, but I was able to just go. I said, hey, don't you look at me like that. Avert your eyes, pal. And then I did six lines through the script in the air air, saunted out of the room, and on my birthday, when it was time for me to go back to New York,
我来这里是为了试镜Fonzie，或者Fonzarelli这个角色。然后我看着那个和我对戏的人，他叫Pasquale。我不知道那是从哪儿来的，但我能够直接进入状态。我说，嘿，别那样看着我。把你的眼睛移开，伙计。然后我对着剧本演了六句台词，大摇大摆地走出房间，在我的生日那天，当我该回纽约的时候，
because I only had a month, they called and said, would you like to play this part? Wow. Wow. And now you're in... Right, I remember you saying that. You were going to go back to New York, you were like, I'm done, I'm going back. Well, I thought, I literally thought,
因为我只有一个月的假，他们打电话说，你想演这个角色吗？哇。哇。现在你在……对，我记得你这么说过。你本来要回纽约，你说，我受够了，我要回去了。好吧，我当时想，我真的想，
well, I don't have any more money. I'm not getting much. Maybe I'm not supposed to be here. But however, you were a Yale grad at this point, yes, out of Yale drama. Yes. So you were stocked full of credentials and ability. Did you not have confidence
好吧，我没钱了。我没得到什么。也许我不该待在这里。但是，你当时是耶鲁大学的毕业生，是的，耶鲁戏剧学院毕业。是的。所以你满载着证书和能力。你没有信心
that you were gonna be able to make a career? I got confidence about last Wednesday. That was the first time. I literally, I've said this before, but imagine that I am a bowl of jello before it congeals in the icebox, in the refrigerator. My insides were shaking like I was at the Rumba Room. Yeah. Yeah, for sure.
你能成就一番事业吗？我大概在上周三才有了信心。那是第一次。我真的，我以前说过，但想象一下我是一碗果冻，在冰箱里凝固之前。我的内心像在伦巴舞厅一样颤抖。是啊。是啊，肯定的。
Was there ever a moment where you didn't wanna talk about playing the Fonz? Like a section of your life where you're just like, I don't wanna talk about it, and then you embraced it or no? No, no, because I understood in those 10 years, the incredible gift that I was given being introduced to the world,
有没有那么一刻你不想谈论扮演Fonz？就像你生命中的某一段时期，你只是觉得，我不想谈论它，然后你又接受了它，或者没有？不，不，因为在那10年里，我理解了我被赋予的不可思议的礼物，被介绍给全世界，
no matter where we went on the planet, somebody stopped me, invited me to their house for dinner. The Native Americans in the Hopi tribe, you have to lock your camera away because they think you're taking their soul. They invited me to get my camera when we took Jed, who is now 53, but at the time was in the third grade, studying Native Americans.
无论我们在地球上的哪个角落，总有人拦住我，邀请我去他们家吃饭。霍皮部落的印第安人，你必须把相机锁起来，因为他们认为你在夺走他们的灵魂。他们邀请我去拿相机，当我们带着Jed的时候，他现在53岁了，但当时还在上三年级，正在学习印第安人。
Yeah. They invited me to get my camera so I could take a picture of the kachina dances. What an honor. Yeah. And that is the microcosm of my life at that time. Did you, and Sean, be honest, are you still thinking about the jello in the fridge?
是啊。他们邀请我去拿相机，这样我就可以拍下卡奇纳舞。多么荣幸。是啊。那是我当时生活的缩影。你，还有Sean，说实话，你还在想冰箱里的果冻吗？
Yes. Did you, Henry, did you? I'm thinking about the leaf, I'm about to drive over to Henry's house and knock out the leaf blower. I'm gonna get him, I'm gonna get him. Yeah, he's next door, he's next door. So, but Henry, I remember seeing photos or video of you like going on these world tours.
是的。Henry，你呢？我在想那个叶子，我正要开车去Henry家，把吹叶机弄坏。我要去抓他，我要去抓他。是啊，他在隔壁，他在隔壁。所以，但是Henry，我记得看过你进行这些世界巡演的照片或视频。
You were in like Japan or something or somewhere. With the Happy Days baseball team. Yeah, was that what it was? Gary Marshall, I miss him every day, was just a brilliant human being. A problem solver, very strict. was just a brilliant human being. A problem solver, very strict. He created Happy Days for the next generation. He created Happy Days and Mork and Mindy and Laverne and Shirley and the odd couple
你在日本还是什么地方。和《欢乐时光》棒球队一起。是那样吗？Gary Marshall，我每天都想念他，他是一个才华横溢的人。一个解决问题的人，非常严格。他为下一代创造了《欢乐时光》。他创造了《欢乐时光》、《Mork and Mindy》、《Laverne and Shirley》和《The Odd Couple》
and on and on and on. And then went on to direct these great movies. Pretty Woman being one of them. Gary Marshall always wanted to own a sports team and I think he bought a part of the Portland Beavers. So we played softball. Then we were invited by the USO and the Happy Days ball team flew to Germany and we played in all these small towns and at that time there was the cold war was still going on and so these men and women were in these small towns at the border of Germany we would play softball with them. I would like to really take this gardener.
等等等等。然后去导演了这些伟大的电影。《漂亮女人》就是其中之一。Gary Marshall一直想拥有一支运动队，我想他买了波特兰海狸队的一部分。所以我们打垒球。然后我们被USO邀请，欢乐时光棒球队飞往德国，我们在所有这些小镇比赛，当时冷战还在继续，所以这些男男女女在德国边境的这些小镇，我们会和他们打垒球。我真的很想带走这个园丁。
Is he in the room? He is like, he's sitting on my lap. Just try using a vacuum cleaner instead. You're so lazy, Henry. You don't need a leaf borer in there. I'm telling you, I don't know. It's the next door neighbor. No, I know, and they're so messy over there.
他在房间里吗？他就像，他坐在我的腿上。试着用吸尘器代替吧。你太懒了，Henry。你不需要吹叶机。我告诉你，我不知道。那是隔壁邻居。不，我知道，他们那边太乱了。
Yeah, no, well, you know, he, yeah. But anyway, so, and then we played all over Germany. Here's the great thing. I'm walking through an airport and a young woman comes up to me with a stroller and said, I was my daughter's age when you came to Germany and played against my dad's team. Wow. Wow.
是啊，不，好吧，你知道，他，是啊。但无论如何，所以，然后我们在德国各地比赛。这是最棒的事情。我走过机场，一个年轻女子推着婴儿车走过来对我说，你来德国和我爸爸的球队比赛时，我还是我女儿这么大。哇。哇。
What? A team. Wow. What a circle. Yeah. Then we went to Okinawa. That's where Scottie was born. And we played again with the American troops in Japan. Yeah. What year was that? That was, Jed was 13. So I have no idea.
什么？一个球队。哇。多么完美的循环。是啊。然后我们去了冲绳。Scottie就是在那儿出生的。我们又和日本的美国军队比赛了。是啊。那是哪一年？那是，Jed 13岁的时候。所以我不知道。
40 years ago. So I have no idea. 40 years ago. So did you guys play just in, only played in access countries, like Japan, Germany, and Italy too? Did you guys play in them? Yes, and then we played in every major ball, ball field in America.
40年前。所以我不知道。40年前。所以你们只是在轴心国比赛吗，比如日本、德国，还有意大利？你们在那些地方比赛吗？是的，然后我们在美国每一个主要的球场都比赛过。
We would play exhibition games before the Mets, before the Giants. Who's on this team? The Dodgers, the Angels. Yeah. Who's on the Happy Days team? Who was there? Ron Howard, a great athlete, believe it or not.
我们在大都会队、巨人队比赛前打表演赛。谁在这个队里？道奇队、天使队。是啊。谁在欢乐时光队？谁在那儿？Ron Howard，信不信由你，是个伟大的运动员。
What position was Richie on? He would play center field, shortstop. Okay. Sure. Donnie Most, great athlete. Where was he? Where do we have Ralph now? Donnie was maybe left field.
Richie是什么位置？他会打中外野手，游击手。好吧。当然。Donnie Most，伟大的运动员。他在哪儿？我们现在让Ralph在哪儿？Donnie可能是左外野手。
Sure. Or second base. And you gotta put Potsy in right, right? The guy in right field. No, he was on first base. Ticket to the game. Potsy in right. First base, oh, okay.
当然。或者二垒手。你得把Potsy放在右边，对吧？右外野手。不，他在一垒。比赛门票。Potsy在右边。一垒，噢，好吧。
You just point and say sit on it, Potsy, and point to first base? Yeah. That is exactly right. And then he went and he was good, he could catch. Okay, yeah. I couldn't catch, so I was the pitcher. They taught me how to pitch, and that is all I could do.
你只是指着说，坐下，Potsy，然后指着一垒？是啊。完全正确。然后他去了，他很棒，他能接球。好吧，是啊。我不会接球，所以我当投手。他们教我怎么投球，这就是我唯一能做的。
Ron Howard bought me a mitt. Anson bought me a bat, my first in my life. Really? And so I got really good at pitching, but if the ball was hit toward me, I turned my body to the left and stop the ball with my body. I was black and blue for eight years. Yeah. Well, you're pitching too many over the middle of the plate. Sounds like. Well,
Ron Howard给我买了一个手套。Anson给我买了一根球棒，我人生中第一根。真的吗？所以我投球变得很厉害，但如果球朝我打来，我就把身体转向左边，用身体挡住球。我青一块紫一块了八年。是啊。好吧，你投了太多好球带中间的球了。听起来是这样。好吧，
I pitch shutouts. What about that was good. Wait a minute. Let's just go by that so quickly. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And now, a word from our sponsor. Smart Let's Get Support from Alexa Emergency Assist. Picture this guys, it's the 20 minutes between your kid getting off the bus and when you get home. A fire starts when they decide to make a snack.
我投出了完封。那有什么好的。等一下。让我们快点跳过这个。是啊。是啊。是啊。是啊。是啊。是啊。现在，来自我们赞助商的消息。SmartLess得到Alexa Emergency Assist的支持。想象一下，伙计们，这是你孩子下校车和你到家之间的20分钟。当他们决定做零食时，火灾发生了。
Do your kids know who to call? Do they know how to say, Alexa, call for help? That's all they need to do to be connected to a dedicated emergency response agent faster than industry standards. Real stories show us time and again, immediate action and information is crucial. Alexa Emergency Assist arms urgent response agents
你的孩子知道该打给谁吗？他们知道怎么说“Alexa，呼叫求助”吗？他们只需要这样做，就能比行业标准更快地连接到专门的紧急响应代理。真实的故事一次又一次地告诉我们，立即的行动和信息至关重要。Alexa Emergency Assist为紧急响应代理提供了
with critical information about you and your family. Additionally, your pre-saved emergency contacts are notified when you call for help and when the call ends. It's really, really great, you guys. I got this a couple weeks ago, and I know I spoke about it before on the show, but Scotty has diabetes, as a lot of you know, and years and years and years ago,
关于你和你家人的关键信息。此外，当你呼叫求助和通话结束时，你预存的紧急联系人会收到通知。这真的非常非常棒，伙计们。我几周前买了它，我知道我之前在节目里提到过，但Scottie有糖尿病，你们很多人都知道，很多很多年前，
like 16, 17 years ago, he had a diabetic seizure. And I didn't know what to do, I didn't know who to call. I didn't know, I panicked. It was freaky to find him like that. Well, thank God it all worked out, and Iicked. It was freaky to find him like that. Well, thank God it all worked out and I used kind of old school techniques to find him help. But now that we have Alexa Emergency Assist set up in the kitchen,
大概16、17年前，他有过一次糖尿病发作。我不知道该怎么办，我不知道该打给谁。我不知道，我惊慌失措。发现他那样真是太可怕了。好吧，谢天谢地一切都解决了，我……发现他那样真是太可怕了。好吧，谢天谢地一切都解决了，我用了老派的方法找到了帮助。但现在我们在厨房里安装了Alexa Emergency Assist，
which is like the central hub of the house, I can't tell you the peace of mind we have. Like if that ever happens again, God forbid, knowing the Alexa Emergency Assist is right there with all of our contact information, how fast they respond, it's all fantastic and it's all peace of mind and it's worth every single penny. So for that added layer of protection for your family, property, and even your pets, trust in the peace of mind that only Alexa Emergency Assist can provide.
这就像房子的中心枢纽，我无法告诉你我们有多安心。如果这种情况再次发生，上帝保佑，知道Alexa Emergency Assist就在那里，有我们所有的联系信息，他们反应有多快，这一切都太棒了，这一切都让人安心，每一分钱都花得值。所以为了给你的家人、财产甚至宠物增加那层保护，相信Alexa Emergency Assist能提供的安心感。
Learn more and subscribe at www.amazon.com slash Alexa Assist. SmartList is brought to you in part by Audible. Listening on Audible helps your imagination soar. Whether you listen to stories, motivation, expert advice, or any genre you love, you can be inspired to imagine new worlds, new possibilities, new ways of thinking. Find the genres you love and discover new ones along the way. Explore bestsellers, new releases, plus thousands of included audio books, podcasts, and originals that members can listen to all they want with more added all the time. Audible makes it easy to be
在www.amazon.com/AlexaAssist了解更多并订阅。SmartLess部分由Audible赞助。在Audible上收听能让你的想象力飞翔。无论你听故事、励志内容、专家建议还是你喜欢的任何类型，你都能受到启发去想象新的世界、新的可能性、新的思维方式。找到你喜欢的类型，并在过程中发现新的类型。探索畅销书、新书，以及成千上万的包含在内的有声书、播客和原创作品，会员可以随心所欲地收听，而且一直在增加。Audible让你很容易
inspired and entertained as part of your daily routine without needing to set aside extra time. There's more to imagine when you listen. You know when Andy Sandberg was on we were talking about the short Lazy Sunday which was by the Lonely Island guys and in it is the Chronicles of Narnia and so that had kind of like stuck with me and I was like, oh you know what, that'd be a great audible book to listen to The Lion, the Witch and the Wardrobe. And because I hadn't read it or listened to it in this case
作为日常生活的一部分受到启发和娱乐，而无需额外留出时间。当你收听时，有更多的想象空间。你知道当Andy Sandberg来的时候，我们谈到了短片《Lazy Sunday》，那是Lonely Island那帮人做的，里面有《纳尼亚传奇》，所以这有点像印在我脑海里，我就想，噢你知道吗，听《狮子、女巫和魔衣橱》那本Audible书会很棒。因为我没读过，或者在这种情况下没听过，
in years and years since I was a kid. So it was really really cool to get lost in that world and hear all those characters again. And it's narrated by Michael York who's fantastic. As an audible member you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases. New members can try Audible free for 30 days.
已经很多年了，自从我小时候起。所以能沉浸在那个世界里，再次听到所有那些角色，真的非常非常酷。而且是由Michael York朗读的，他太棒了。作为Audible会员，你每个月可以选择一本作品保留，来自整个目录，包括最新的畅销书和新书。新会员可以免费试用Audible 30天。
Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try Audible free for 30 days, audible.com slash smartless. Smartless gets support from Zip Recruiter. www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com
访问audible.com/smartless或发送短信smartless到500-500。那是audible.com/smartless或发送短信smartless到500-500来免费试用Audible 30天，audible.com/smartless。SmartLess得到ZipRecruiter的支持。www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com
www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com Whether you're hiring for one of those roles or any other role, how do you find top talent before the competition gets to them? ZipRecruiter.
www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com www.sportscope.com 无论你是在招聘这些职位中的一个还是任何其他职位，你如何在竞争对手抢先之前找到顶尖人才？ZipRecruiter。
And right now you can try ZipRecruiter for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartlist. ZipRecruiter's got this powerful matching technology that really digs in to find you top-notch talent for roles you're looking to fill. As soon as you post your job, ZipRecruiter's smart technology shows you the qualified peeps that are a perfect fit. Gear up for summer with ZipRecruiter's high-speed hiring tools. See why four out of five employers who post on ZipRecruiter
现在你可以在ziprecruiter.com/smartlist免费试用ZipRecruiter。ZipRecruiter拥有强大的匹配技术，能深入挖掘，为你找到你想要填补职位的顶尖人才。一旦你发布了工作，ZipRecruiter的智能技术就会向你展示完美的合格人选。用ZipRecruiter的高速招聘工具为夏天做好准备。看看为什么五分之四在ZipRecruiter上发布职位的雇主
get a quality candidate within the first day. Just go to this exclusive web address right now to try ZipRecruiter for free. ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. Again, that's ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. And now, back to the show.
在第一天内就能得到高质量的候选人。现在就去这个独家网址免费试用ZipRecruiter。ZipRecruiter.com/smartless。再说一遍，是ZipRecruiter.com/smartless。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。现在，回到节目。
I want to get to you, is it true that when you, what your audition for Yale, when you went into Yale drama school, that you completely blanked on your Shakespearean monologue, you made one up? Is that true? So you improvised in Shakespearean iambic pentameter. No, not in iambic pentameter, but I told the story, it was, the monologue was Lantz and his dog.
我想问你，是不是真的当你，你耶鲁的试镜，当你进入耶鲁戏剧学院时，你完全忘记了你的莎士比亚独白，你编了一个？是真的吗？所以你即兴创作了莎士比亚的抑扬五步格。不，不是抑扬五步格，但我讲了这个故事，它是，独白是《维洛那二绅士》里的兰斯和他的狗。
I don't even remember what play it was from because I know my limitations. This was out of my perfume. Right. And I went L the out of my perfume. Right. And I went to launch and the dog. And then I said went for a walk and I made it up. And they still let you in. Absolutely brilliant.
我甚至不记得它是哪部戏里的了，因为我知道我的局限性。这超出了我的能力范围。对。然后我去了兰斯和狗。然后我说去散步，我就编造了它。他们还是让你进去了。绝对天才。
Not only did they let me okay, so there are 25 actors started 11 finished. I was one of three actors asked into the professional company, I now am making $172 a week. I am starting my dream. I am eight, thinking about being a professional actor, I am now being paid. I don't know.
他们不仅让我……好吧，有25个演员开始，11个完成。我是三个被邀请进入专业剧团的演员之一，我现在每周赚172美元。我开始了我的梦想。我八岁，想着成为一名专业演员，我现在被付钱了。我不知道。
Then I got a $10 raise, went to one of the best repertory theaters in the country in Washington, D.C. It was Moon Children. That was a cast. That's hysterical. Michael Tucker, Jill Eikenberry, Chris Guest, just on and on.
然后我涨了10美元工资，去了华盛顿特区最好的剧目剧院之一。那是《Moon Children》。那是一个演员阵容。太搞笑了。Michael Tucker，Jill Eikenberry，Chris Guest，等等等等。
Jimmy Woods. Oh wow, James Woods. Oh my God. Now, so how did you, did you get to Yale via acting chops or were you an academic? I am in the bottom 3% academically in America. So then what are you doing over at Yale? Well, I was all just auditioning.
Jimmy Woods。噢哇，James Woods。噢天哪。那么，你是通过表演技巧进入耶鲁的，还是你是个学霸？我在美国的学术成绩处于后3%。那你在耶鲁干什么？好吧，我只是在试镜。
I was just, it's just your ability to impress them as an actor. What at eight years old made you want to act? Was it that dance thing that you saw? That is a good question. I'm not sure. My standard answer is if people were born to try and do something, I was born to try and be an actor.
这只是你作为演员打动他们的能力。八岁时是什么让你想演戏？是你看到的那个舞蹈吗？这是个好问题。我不确定。我的标准答案是，如果人们生来就是为了尝试做某事，我生来就是为了尝试成为一名演员。
Wow. But did you have that in your family? Did your parents encourage it? Did you guys go see a lot of shows? My parents encouraged me, not an iota. And my father brought a lumber business over from Germany. He imported and exported wood. And he wanted me to do the same. He wanted me to take over the business. And my joke is he said to me, why do you think I bought the business over here? And I said, besides being chased by the Nazis, dad,
哇。但你的家庭里有这个吗？你的父母鼓励吗？你们经常去看演出吗？我的父母鼓励我，一点点都没有。我父亲从德国带过来一家木材生意。他进口和出口木材。他想让我做同样的事。他想让我接管生意。我的笑话是，他对我说了，你以为我为什么把生意带到这里？我说，除了被纳粹追赶，爸爸，
was there like a bigger reason? Right, right, right. Oh my God. Hey, Henry, what year did your mom and dad come over from Germany? Was it in the 30s? 1939. Wow.
还有什么更大的原因吗？对，对，对。噢天哪。嘿，Henry，你爸妈是哪一年从德国过来的？是在30年代吗？1939年。哇。
My father asked his mother and took my mother's jewelry, bought a box of chocolate, melted the chocolate, poured the chocolate over the jewelry, put it back in the box, put the box under his arm, and then got a work visa for six weeks. So when the Nazi said, are you taking anything of value? He said, no, open my bags, check my pockets,
我父亲问了他的母亲，拿了我母亲的珠宝，买了一盒巧克力，融化了巧克力，把巧克力倒在珠宝上，放回盒子里，把盒子夹在腋下，然后拿到了六周的工作签证。所以当纳粹说，你带了什么有价值的东西吗？他说，没有，打开我的包，检查我的口袋，
I have nothing. And that box of chocolate started him on his new life because he pawned all of the jewelry until he was able to buy it back. And I have my great grandfather's pocket watch that came out of jewelry encased in chocolate. Wow. That's usually right with the gold coin.
我什么都没有。那盒巧克力开启了他的新生活，因为他典当了所有的珠宝，直到他能赎回来。我有我曾祖父的怀表，就是从巧克力包裹的珠宝里出来的。哇。通常是金币。
It's usually gold on the outside and chocolate in the middle. This time it was reversed. Yes. Yes. And that chocolate, you couldn't eat it. You could not eat it. It always gave you herpes. But that, but what an amazing, what an amazing story.
通常外面是金子，中间是巧克力。这次反过来了。是的。是的。那巧克力，你不能吃。你不能吃。它总是让你长疱疹。但那……但多么令人惊奇，多么令人惊奇的故事。
And so when your father comes, so I get it, you sort of, the way you characterize him, he's like, he was tough. He wanted you to take over the lumber business, but I'm sure in his mind he's like, hey, I came in tough times. You're right. We were persecuted.
所以当你父亲来的时候，我明白了，你描述他的方式，他很强硬。他想让你接管木材生意，但我肯定在他心里他想，嘿，我经历了艰难时期。你是对的。我们受到了迫害。
You're right. I understand all of that. I swear. I do. I admire. They learned a new language. He started a business in a new country. He didn't know if he would be able to stay.
你是对的。我理解所有这些。我发誓。我理解。我很钦佩。他们学习了一种新语言。他在一个新国家开创了事业。他不知道他是否能留下来。
But here it is. When you have a child and they're in front of you, they're not an extension of who you are. They're not there to make you proud. And if you see your child is got a problem, even if you don't know the name, if you don't understand it, your job is to make sure that that child
但就是这样。当你有一个孩子，他们在你面前时，他们不是你自己的延伸。他们不是为了让你骄傲而存在的。如果你看到你的孩子有问题，即使你不知道名字，如果你不理解它，你的工作是确保那个孩子
feels comfortable enough not to lose their entire self-esteem, but to help them meet their destiny, not get proud of them when they figured out how to meet their destiny all by themselves. Right. That's an interesting thing. Yeah, because you had to battle through
感到足够舒适，不会失去他们所有的自尊，而是帮助他们实现他们的命运，而不是当他们自己弄清楚如何实现命运时才为他们感到骄傲。对。那是一件有趣的事情。是啊，因为你不得不克服
some pretty significant dyslexia challenges, yes? I still do. You don't lose it. Dyslexia is with you, you just have to learn to negotiate it and there are things I just can't do and then there are other people who I depend on to do it. Thank God Stacey, my wife, is a brilliant speller. But it's hereditary, I'm sorry.
一些相当严重的阅读障碍挑战，对吧？我仍然有。你不会失去它。阅读障碍伴随着你，你只需要学会应对它，有些事情我就是做不到，然后有其他人我依赖他们去做。谢天谢地Stacey，我的妻子，是个拼写天才。但它是遗传的，抱歉。
Well I was gonna say, you've written books about it. You've been really vocal about it in terms of identifying it in kids and helping them because of your own experience and using that to try to talk about it. Is that right? Am I right about that? I did not know that that was going to happen. In 2001, I had just finished a Broadway play with John Ritter and Len Cario. Right. It was a Neil Simon play. Oh my God, it was my dream. The first play I did, open and closed in one night.
好吧，我正想说，你写过关于它的书。你一直非常直言不讳，在识别孩子的问题并帮助他们方面，因为你自己的经历，并利用这一点试图谈论它。那是对的吗？我关于那个是对的吗？我不知道会发生那种事。2001年，我刚和John Ritter和Len Cario演完一部百老汇戏剧。对。那是一部Neil Simon的戏。噢天哪，那是我的梦想。我演的第一部戏，演了一晚就关门了。
This one ran for nine months. Wow. Wow. So I come home, can't get hired. I go to a friend and I said, I don't know what to do, I need help. He said, write books for children about your learning condition. I said, I can't do it because I've got a learning problem. He said, I'm going to introduce you to Lynn Oliver. And then you know what I found out? The lesson is there is not one way to do anything. There is your way, and your way is as valid
这一部演了九个月。哇。哇。所以我回家了，雇不到人。我去找一个朋友说，我不知道该怎么办，我需要帮助。他说，为孩子们写关于你的学习障碍的书。我说，我做不到，因为我有学习问题。他说，我要把你介绍给Lynn Oliver。然后你知道我发现了什么吗？教训是，做任何事都没有唯一的方法。有你的方法，而你的方法和
as any other way. Was there any kind of, while you were discovering that you had dyslexia, did you know something was wrong, and did you do anything to try to hide it? I used humor, I used humor I used humor so I I couldn't read I couldn't read off a page. Yeah, I couldn't spell I still can't spell look I have over my
任何其他方法一样有效。在你发现你有阅读障碍时，有没有什么，你知道有什么不对劲，你有没有做任何事试图隐藏它？我用了幽默，我用了幽默，我用了幽默，所以我……我不能读，我不能读页面上的东西。是啊，我不会拼写，我仍然不会拼写，看，我在我的
Computer I have words schedule that I can't Sound out and really so they're there, because I use them so often, like the word schedule, and I just look up and that's how I spell it. Wow. Yeah, I remember when I was a kid in school, I knew I had problems with my eyes,
电脑上，我有单词“schedule”，我不能拼出来，真的，所以它们在那儿，因为我经常用它们，比如“schedule”这个词，我就抬头看，那就是我拼写它的方式。哇。是啊，我记得我小时候在学校，我知道我的眼睛有问题，
I couldn't see, and I sat in the back of the class, and the class had two doors, one at the front entrance of the class and one at the end, and I would ask to go to the bathroom, and I would leave the classroom, go up the hallway to the front entrance and there was just a little vestibule before you opened it
我看不见，我坐在教室后面，教室有两个门，一个在教室前门，一个在后面，我会要求去洗手间，我会离开教室，走到走廊去前门，那里有一个小门厅，在你打开它之前
and I would look through the glass to read the blackboard to see what was on it and I would go back to my desk in the back of the class. Because I was too embarrassed, I was like, I can't see the- I understand. Henry, I'm borrowing Sean, I'm at Sean's desk and I just found this over his computer.
我会透过玻璃看黑板，看看上面写了什么，然后回到教室后面的座位上。因为我太尴尬了，我想，我看不见……我明白了。亨利，我要借用一下肖恩，我在肖恩的桌子旁，刚才在他的电脑上发现了这个。
You can probably see spaghetti and meatballs. I don't know why. Can I just say something? Corbin affirmation. Can I just say something? Each one of you, I know individually, I know, you know, I met the two of you, I met you at the first day of doing Arrested Development. You were on the couch in the living room.
你可能看到了意大利面和肉丸。我不知道为什么。我能说点什么吗？科尔宾的肯定。我能说点什么吗？你们每个人，我都很了解，我知道，你们知道，我是在拍摄《发展受阻》的第一天认识你们俩的。当时你们坐在客厅的沙发上。
I was your lawyer and not very good. And Sean, I met at Max Munchnik's party and I was so overwhelmed by meeting him that I was a little out of body, and he looked at me, I said, oh, I'm so, and he looked at me and went, hello. And I thought, oh, I've completely screwed that up. Oh, God, no, I was probably dying inside.
我是你们的律师，而且不太称职。肖恩，我是在马克斯·穆尼奇克的派对上认识你的，见到他我太激动了，以至于有点灵魂出窍，他看着我，我说，哦，我太……他看着我，说了声“你好”。我想，哦，我彻底搞砸了。哦，天哪，不，我当时可能尴尬得要死。
But that is, I'm so happy to be with you. Henry, can I tell you something? I have so many great memories, and people ask me all the time about working with you, and obviously you're an icon, and I say, I have a bunch of really distinct, and they're all good memories of you, and I tell you them sort of in no particular way.
但能和你们在一起我真的很高兴。亨利，我能告诉你一件事吗？我有太多美好的回忆，人们总是问我关于和你一起工作的事，显然你是偶像，我说，我有很多非常深刻的，而且都是关于你的美好回忆，我以一种随意的顺序告诉你。
One is, and Jay, you were there, we were doing a scene, you, me and Jason, and you, Henry, and Jeffrey Tambor, and we were doing a scene in a bathroom at the old season one. And we were doing the scene in a bathroom, I forget the conversation in the scene, and then we all leave the room,
一个是，杰伊，你当时也在场，我们在拍一场戏，你、我和杰森，还有你，亨利，以及杰弗里·坦博，我们在第一季的老浴室里拍一场戏。我们在浴室里拍那场戏，我忘了戏里的对话了，然后我们都离开了房间，
and at the end, you're left in the bathroom, you look in the mirror, you go to comb your hair and you go, nah. Like that Fonzie move. But really subtly and then you walk out. So that was my first, and I remember Jason and I going like, can you believe we're doing this scene and he's doing a fucking Fonzie thing? How lucky are we that we get to be doing it?
最后，你一个人留在浴室里，看着镜子，去梳头，然后说，不。就像方兹那个动作。但非常微妙，然后你走了出去。那是我的第一次，我记得杰森和我当时想，你能相信我们正在拍这场戏，而他正在做那个该死的方兹动作吗？我们能参与其中是多么幸运啊？
A, that's my A. My B is this, my first year of Arrested Development, I was living in LA part-time just at work. And I had a few friends, Jason being one of them, and Sean and I weren't that friendly yet. I didn't really like him that much. But I was on my own often, and on the weekends, if I didn't go back to New York, I was on my own.
A，这是我的A。我的B是这个，我拍《发展受阻》的第一年，我因为工作在洛杉矶兼职居住。我有几个朋友，杰森是其中之一，我和肖恩当时还没那么熟。我其实不太喜欢他。但我经常一个人，周末如果不回纽约，我就一个人。
And you and your wife, Stacey, welcomed me in your home a few times. On a Saturday morning, you'd say, come over and we'd do breakfast and bagels and blah, blah, blah, blah. And you were so kind. It's where I met Jed. It's where I met all your kids. And I, Max, and I was like, this is unbelievable. So kind. You took your time
你和你的妻子斯泰西几次欢迎我到你们家。周六早上，你会说，过来吧，我们吃早餐、吃百吉饼等等等等。你太善良了。我就是在那里认识杰德的。我就是在那里认识你所有孩子的。我，马克斯，当时想，这真是不可思议。太善良了。你花时间
and you welcomed me into your home. And I honestly, I never forget it to this day, how kind that was of you. I love it. Well, you know, you're all invited. There is a seat at my table. I had the pleasure of having Jason and his incredible wife for dinner.
欢迎我到你家。老实说，直到今天我都不会忘记，你当时有多善良。我喜欢这样。嗯，你知道，你们都受邀了。我的餐桌上总有一个位置。我有幸请到杰森和他了不起的妻子共进晚餐。
And the only one who hasn't been here is Sean. Yeah, Amanda and I went over there and Zoe was there and Rob was there, the great Rob Reinis. Oh, I was gonna say that, and then Zoe and Rob. And of course I've come to know Rob, your son-in-law, obviously over the years he built my house, he's an incredible guy. He's so good, isn't he?
唯一没来过这里的是肖恩。是的，阿曼达和我去过那里，佐伊也在，罗布也在，伟大的罗布·雷尼斯。哦，我正想说这个，还有佐伊和罗布。当然，这些年来我认识了罗布，你的女婿，显然他盖了我的房子，他是个了不起的人。他太棒了，不是吗？
He's incredible. I had a conversation with him outside, maybe, but he was an actor, He was a really good actor. He wanted to date my daughter and I said I Just want to tell you you better earn a living Because this is not a easy person We can cut it out, but what's Rob's last name Rob Reines Rob Reines, so he wanted to be an actor, and I said, oh, you. Yeah, he's the contractor.
他太不可思议了。我可能在外面和他聊过，但他以前是个演员，他是个非常好的演员。他想和我女儿约会，我说我只想告诉你，你最好能挣钱，因为这不是一个容易相处的人。我们可以剪掉这段，但罗布的姓是什么？罗布·雷尼斯。罗布·雷尼斯，所以他想当演员，我说，哦，你。是的，他是承包商。
He's the great, you want something built in Los Angeles. He's a great builder of homes. He and his partner, Brian. And you know what, and so that was the conversation. So he then went to his father's friend, got a job, because his father's friend is also a very good building company. And he started in the parking lot where the crew would come and he would move the cars
他是最棒的，你想在洛杉矶盖房子，找他就对了。他是很棒的房屋建筑商。他和他的合伙人布莱恩。你知道吗，谈话就是这样。所以他后来去找了他父亲的朋友，找了份工作，因为他父亲的朋友也是一家非常好的建筑公司。他从停车场开始干起，工作人员会来，他负责挪车，
around so they all fit in the small space of the parking for the day. And he met Brian, who was part of the crew. And together they have made this wonderful company. Sean, Sean, VR, the company's called VRB, and you know my old house that I used to have up the hill? They built, Rob built that house. Yeah, I met the guy. And then the house I'm in now, Rob completely redid it and did everything.
好让车子在白天都能停在狭小的空间里。他遇到了也是工作人员之一的布莱恩。他们一起创办了这家很棒的公司。肖恩，肖恩，VR，公司叫VRB，你知道我以前在山上住的那栋房子吗？他们盖的，罗布盖了那栋房子。是的，我见过那个人。还有我现在住的房子，罗布完全翻新了，做了所有事情。
And I try, anytime, anything, he's the best, this is the kind of guy Rob is. When he built that other house that I used to live in, something fucked up when we were gonna do this and we're gonna have a deck and usually, and it came in, it wasn't quite right and the wood was, and usually guys, you know, contacts go, well, that's the way it is,
我试过，无论什么时候，任何事情，他都是最好的，这就是罗布那种人。当他盖我以前住的那栋房子时，我们要做这个的时候出了点岔子，我们要有一个露台，通常，结果做出来不太对，木头也……通常那些家伙，你知道，承包商会说，好吧，就是这样，
too bad you gotta pay blah, blah, blah. Rob says, I'm rebuilding the deck, I'm paying for the, I'm paying for the, the labor, the lumber, everything, that's not your fault, I'm taking the deck. I'm paying for the labor, the lumber, everything. That's not your fault, I'm taking care of it. And I said, Rob, you don't have to, he goes, no, I have to do it. That's the kind of guy he is.
太糟糕了，你得付钱等等。罗布说，我来重建露台，我来付人工费、木材费，所有费用，这不是你的错，我来承担。我来付人工费、木材费，所有费用。这不是你的错，我来处理。我说，罗布，你没必要这样，他说，不，我必须这么做。他就是那种人。
That's amazing. That's amazing. Hey, Sean, Sean, can I ask you a question? Yes. This has been on my mind for a long time. Are you going to bring your Broadway award-winning show to LA?
太棒了。太棒了。嘿，肖恩，肖恩，我能问你个问题吗？可以。这件事我一直记在心里。你打算把你在百老汇获奖的演出带到洛杉矶吗？
No, it's had a marvelous life. I wanna tell you for the listening audience who did not have the extraordinary experience of seeing Good Night Oscar on Broadway, Sean Hayes, first of all, disappeared. You know Sean, and you saw nothing of the Sean you know on that stage. And then you find out he is a concert pianist,
不，它已经有了精彩的一生。我想告诉那些没有看过百老汇《晚安，奥斯卡》的听众，肖恩·海耶斯，首先，他消失了。你认识肖恩，你在舞台上完全看不到你认识的那个肖恩。然后你发现他是一位音乐会钢琴家，
and for 30 minutes plays the piano concert-ready. minutes, plays the piano, concert ready, the audience jettisoned out of their seats. They lept out of their seats. That's very sweet of you. It was electrifying. It really was. Recently? This is a recent project, Sean?
并且在30分钟内演奏了达到音乐会水准的钢琴曲。分钟，演奏钢琴，达到音乐会水准，观众从座位上弹了起来。他们跳了起来。你太贴心了。这真是令人振奋。确实如此。最近吗？这是一个最近的项目吗，肖恩？
Yes it is, yes it is. It was about a year ago. You were crying right next to me, Willie. And then Sean, Sean went and go ahead and then he took a Tony Award for it. It's very nice. And Henry, you were very sweet to even talk about it. And I saw you on a morning talk show talk about it.
是的，是的。大约是一年前。威利，你当时就在我旁边哭。然后肖恩，肖恩去……继续说，然后他因此获得了托尼奖。这太好了。亨利，你能谈论它真是太好了。我在早间脱口秀节目里看到你谈论它。
I was floored. I was like, oh my God, one of my childhood idols is talking so lovely about me. So it was really. But if you did not win the Tony, there would have been something wrong with the universe. That's very nice. I agree.
我惊呆了。我想，天哪，我童年的偶像之一竟然如此可爱地谈论我。所以这真的很……但如果你没有赢得托尼奖，那宇宙就出问题了。这太好了。我同意。
That's true. We'll be right back. I'm Mike Bubbins. I'm Ellis James. And I'm Steph Guerrero. And we're convinced that our podcast, The Socially Distanced Sports Bar, is going to be your new favorite comedy podcast with just a little bit of sport thrown in. You don't have to love sport, like sport or even
确实如此。我们马上回来。我是迈克·巴宾斯。我是埃利斯·詹姆斯。我是斯蒂芬·格雷罗。我们确信我们的播客《保持社交距离的体育酒吧》将成为你最喜欢的新喜剧播客，里面还加了一点点体育内容。你不必热爱体育、喜欢体育，甚至
know anything about sport to listen. Because nobody has conversations which stay on topic and it's the same on our podcast we might start off talking about ice hockey but end up discussing I don't know 1980s British sitcom Alo Alo instead. Imagine using the word nuance in your pitch for Aloha Lo. He's not cheating on his wife, he's French. It's a different culture. If you like me and Mammoth, or you like Alice and fantasy football league, then you'll love our podcast.
不需要了解任何体育知识就能收听。因为没人会一直聊正题，我们的播客也一样，我们可能从冰球开始聊，最后却讨论起1980年代的英国情景喜剧《阿洛阿洛》了。想象一下在推销《阿洛阿洛》时使用“细微差别”这个词。他没有背叛妻子，他是法国人。这是不同的文化。如果你喜欢我和猛犸象，或者你喜欢爱丽丝和梦幻足球联盟，那你一定会喜欢我们的播客。
Follow the Socially Distant Sports Bar wherever you get your podcasts. The Socially Distant Sports Bar, it's not about asymmetrical overlords. James, podcasting from his study, and you have to say that's magnificent. podcasts. The socially distant sports bar. It's not about asymmetrical overloads. James podcasting from his study and you have to say that's magnificent. It's all a lighthearted nightmare on our podcast, morbid. We're your hosts. I'm Alina Urquhart. And I'm Ash Kelly. And our show is part true crime, part spooky and part comedy. The stories we cover are well researched, He claimed and confessed to officially killing up to 28 people.
在任何你获取播客的地方关注《保持社交距离的体育酒吧》。《保持社交距离的体育酒吧》，这不是关于不对称的霸主。詹姆斯，在书房里录制播客，你不得不说这太壮观了。播客。《保持社交距离的体育酒吧》。这不是关于不对称的霸主。詹姆斯在书房里录制播客，你不得不说这太壮观了。在我们的播客《病态》里，这一切都是一场轻松的噩梦。我们是主持人。我是阿丽娜·厄克特。我是阿什·凯利。我们的节目部分是真实犯罪，部分是灵异，部分是喜剧。我们讲述的故事经过了充分的研究，他声称并承认杀害了多达28人。
with a touch of humor, I just like to go ahead and say that if there's no band called Malevolent Deity, that is pretty great. a dash of sarcasm, and just garnished a bit with a little bit of cursing. This mother f***er lied. Like a little bit of cursing. This mother-f***er lied. Like a liar. Like a liar. And if you're a weirdo like us and love to cozy up to a creepy tale of the paranormal,
带有一点幽默感，我只想说，如果没有一支叫“邪恶神灵”的乐队，那真是太棒了。带有一点讽刺，再加一点点咒骂。这个混蛋撒谎了。像一点点咒骂。这个混蛋撒谎了。像个骗子。像个骗子。如果你像我们一样是个怪人，喜欢蜷缩起来听一个令人毛骨悚然的超自然故事，
or you love to hop in the way back machine and dissect the details of some of history's most notorious crimes, you should tune in to our podcast, Morbid. Follow Morbid on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to episodes early and ad-free by joining Wondery Plus and the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to episodes early and ad free by joining Wondery Plus and the Wondery app or on Apple podcasts. Nancy's love story could have been ripped right out of the pages of one of her own novels. She was a romance mystery writer who happens to be married to a chef. But this story didn't end with a happily ever after. When I stepped into the kitchen, I could see that Chef Brophy was on the ground,
或者你喜欢跳进时光机，剖析历史上一些最臭名昭著的犯罪细节，你应该收听我们的播客《病态》。在Wondery应用程序或任何你获取播客的地方关注《病态》。你可以通过加入Wondery Plus在Wondery应用程序或任何你获取播客的地方提前收听无广告的剧集。你可以通过加入Wondery Plus在Wondery应用程序或Apple播客上提前收听无广告的剧集。南希的爱情故事本可以直接从她自己的小说中撕下来。她是一位浪漫悬疑小说作家，恰好嫁给了一位厨师。但这个故事并没有以幸福快乐结局。当我走进厨房时，我看到布罗菲厨师倒在地上，
and I heard somebody say, call 911. As writers, we'd written our share of murder mysteries. So when suspicion turned to Dan's wife, Nancy, we weren't that surprised. The first person they look at would be the spouse. We understand that's usually the way they do it. But we began to wonder, had Nancy gotten so wrapped up in her own novels, there are murders in all of the books, that she was playing them out in real life? Follow Happily Never After, Dan and Nancy on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can binge all episodes of Happily Never After, Dan and Nancy early and ad-free right now by joining Wondery Plus.
我听到有人说，打911。作为作家，我们写过不少谋杀悬疑小说。所以当怀疑转向丹的妻子南希时，我们并不感到惊讶。他们调查的第一个人通常就是配偶。我们明白这通常是他们做事的方式。但我们开始怀疑，南希是否太沉迷于她自己的小说了，所有的书里都有谋杀案，以至于她在现实生活中上演了这些情节？在Wondery应用程序或任何你获取播客的地方关注《从此不再幸福：丹与南希》。你可以通过加入Wondery Plus，现在就提前收听《从此不再幸福：丹与南希》的所有剧集，且无广告。
From Wondery, I'm Raaza Jafri, and this is The Spy Who. This series, we open the file on Eamonn Dean, the spy who betrayed Bin Laden. In 1994, 16-year-old Eman wants to die. He heads to war-torn Bosnia to join the Mujahideen and save his fellow Muslims. He hopes to become a martyr so that he can be reunited with his dead parents in paradise. Instead, he's about to be confronted by a cruel and bloody reality.
来自Wondery，我是拉扎·贾弗里，这是《间谍是谁》。本系列，我们打开埃蒙·迪恩的档案，那个背叛本·拉登的间谍。1994年，16岁的埃曼想死。他前往饱受战争蹂躏的波斯尼亚加入圣战组织，拯救他的穆斯林同胞。他希望成为一名烈士，这样他就能在天堂与死去的父母团聚。相反，他即将面对残酷而血腥的现实。
A reality that will lead him to turn his back on terrorism and become the West's top spy inside Al-Qaeda. Follow The Spy Who on the Wanderer app, or wherever you listen to podcasts. Or you can binge the full season of The Spy Who, betrayed Bin Laden early and ad-free with Wanderer+. And now, back to the show. Henry, so you shoot out of the stratosphere with Happy Days.
一个将导致他背弃恐怖主义，成为西方在基地组织内部顶级间谍的现实。在Wondery应用程序或任何你收听播客的地方关注《间谍是谁》。或者你可以通过Wondery+提前收听《间谍是谁：背叛本·拉登》的全季内容，且无广告。现在，回到节目。亨利，你凭借《欢乐时光》一飞冲天。
You are arguably one of the most famous men in the world. You probably can't walk down the street. What was that adjustment like? And then I want you to talk to me about the adjustment afterwards when you couldn't possibly match that level of success or profile. How did you weather that sort of gap
你大概是世界上最著名的人之一。你可能没法走在街上。那种调整是什么样的？然后我想让你谈谈之后当你无法匹配那种成功或知名度水平时的调整。你是如何度过那种
between the end of happy days and the highlights that followed after that, because you can't keep it up at that level, and how did you manage the swale? Those are two really great questions. I swear to God, I think I have to really give it to my dyslexia, because there's an emotional component that goes on. Your lack of self, no matter how you appear on the outside,
《欢乐时光》结束后的差距，以及随后的亮点，因为你无法保持那种水平，你是如何应对这种波动的？这是两个非常好的问题。我向上帝发誓，我想我真的得归功于我的阅读障碍，因为这其中有一个情感成分。你的自我缺失，无论你在外表上看起来如何，
is churning on the inside. So people talking to me like I can walk on water, I keep looking over my shoulder because they can't possibly be talking to me. Because they don't know who I am. Because, you know, so I was able to keep grounded. Then I met Stacey, which did an even better job. And then Jed came with the marriage.
内心都在翻腾。所以人们跟我说话好像我能水上行走，我一直回头看，因为他们不可能是在跟我说话。因为他们不知道我是谁。因为，你知道，所以我能够保持脚踏实地。然后我遇到了斯泰西，她做得更好。然后杰德随着婚姻而来。
He was a gift with the marriage. And that, painting his face to look like Kiss, the marriage and that painting his face to look like kiss kept you focused on what is in the moment and has nothing to do with who you are. I had the most amazing time. Now it comes, I have an office, I have a production deal because of Skip Brittenham the third. And now I am not getting any calls or callbacks.
他是婚姻带来的礼物。那，把他的脸画成Kiss乐队的样子，婚姻和那把脸画成Kiss的样子让你专注于当下，这与你是谁无关。我度过了最美妙的时光。现在来了，我有一个办公室，因为斯基普·布里滕汉三世，我有一个制作协议。现在我没有接到任何电话或回电。
And I'm having like psychic pain. I'm telling you, there was a pain in my brain from not having any idea of what to do next. I had a plan A and I just lived it. I had no plan B. And then I literally thought it's over. And I had the fear, what do I do? Will it match it?
我有一种心理上的痛苦。我告诉你，我的大脑里有一种痛苦，因为不知道下一步该做什么。我有一个A计划，我刚刚实现了它。我没有B计划。然后我真的以为一切都结束了。我有恐惧，我该做什么？它能匹配吗？
Could I ever match it? Same thing happened just now. We just finished Barry at the end of last year. Yeah. Will I match it? Same thing happened just now. We just finished Barry at the end of last year. Yeah. Will I match it? Will I, thank you, thank you. I'm standing. I'm taking a bow.
我能匹配它吗？刚才也发生了同样的事情。我们去年年底刚拍完《巴里》。是的。我会匹配它吗？刚才也发生了同样的事情。我们去年年底刚拍完《巴里》。是的。我会匹配它吗？我会，谢谢，谢谢。我站着。我在鞠躬。
Mm-hmm. Yes. I could have, yeah, I could. Okay. It was palpable. And then my lawyer, Skip, said, I'm gonna start a production company for you So here's another lesson. I learned I
嗯。是的。我可以，是的，我可以。好吧。那是显而易见的。然后我的律师，斯基普，说，我要为你创办一家制作公司。所以这是另一个教训。我学到了我
Said I can't do that. I know nothing about business. I I'm dyslexic. He said you'll learn and You know something so there were things about being a producer I could do And the other things I found people who could do it better. But it was. So this was Fair Dinkum, this is the production company that was set up after Happy Days, and the acting calls were not during, and the acting calls were not coming post Happy Days.
说我做不到。我对商业一无所知。我有阅读障碍。他说你会学的。你知道吗，所以有些关于做制片人的事情我能做。而其他事情我找到了能做得更好的人。但它是。所以这是Fair Dinkum，这是《欢乐时光》之后成立的制作公司，而表演邀约并没有在期间，表演邀约在《欢乐时光》之后并没有到来。
But for eight years. But during that time, out of desperation or creativity or whatever it was, you started to diversify into producing and directing as well, yes, and this is where directing those movies came along and a little bit later, MacGyver, yeah? Oh yeah, MacGyver.
但持续了八年。但在那段时间里，出于绝望或创造力或其他什么原因，你开始多元化发展，也开始制作和导演，是的，这就是导演那些电影的时候，稍晚一点，还有《百战天龙》，是吗？哦，是的，《百战天龙》。
MacGyver was the first show that we ever produced. I had three different partners, writing partners, who were going to create the material to do my on-air commitments. At that time, they paid you not only compensation, but they gave you, if you brought them a show like ABC, if you brought ABC a show they liked, they would put it right on.
《百战天龙》是我们制作的第一部剧。我有三个不同的合伙人，写作合伙人，他们将创造材料来履行我的出镜承诺。当时，他们不仅支付你报酬，而且如果你给他们带来像ABC这样的节目，如果你给ABC带来他们喜欢的节目，他们会直接播出。
You didn't have to go through the process. So I had two of those. And MacGyver was- I didn't know you produced MacGyver. That's crazy. Yeah, that was the first one that we ever brought to ABC. Yeah. And what were the two?
你不需要经历那个过程。所以我有两个这样的。而《百战天龙》是……我不知道你制作了《百战天龙》。这太疯狂了。是的，那是我们带给ABC的第一部。是的。那两个是什么？
What was the other one? The other one was with Jeff Tambor where he played a blind English professor. So funny. It was called Mr. Sunshine. But we only did 13. It did not last. I remember. But it was great.
另一个是什么？另一个是和杰夫·坦博合作的，他扮演一位失明的英语教授。太搞笑了。它叫《阳光先生》。但我们只拍了13集。它没能持续下去。我记得。但它很棒。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I was going to try to guess. I was going to say a good title for that would have been wear my glasses So so you so you start producing that and you and MacGyver gets on the air it takes off it's it's a big head Yeah, you know, it went for 13 years Seven the first iteration and then we brought it back for five So that it was a pretty terrific run Did Forte and John Salmon those guys have to reach out to you when they started doing the Gruber didn't like those McGrue Did you like those McGrue were spin? I did I did I think will is is unbelievable
是的，是的，是的。我本来想猜。我本来想说一个好的标题应该是《戴上我的眼镜》。所以你开始制作那个，然后《百战天龙》播出了，它起飞了，这是一个大热门。是的，你知道，它播了13年。第一版七年，然后我们带回了五年。所以这是一个相当了不起的历程。福特和约翰·萨尔蒙那些人开始做《麦格鲁》时，他们不得不联系你吗？你不喜欢那些《麦格鲁》吗？你喜欢那些《麦格鲁》衍生剧吗？我喜欢，我喜欢，我认为威尔令人难以置信。
Yeah, and no, but no, they did not reach out to me. I did, you know it because it was owned by Paramount and ABC at the time Right, so so you, right, right. So you do that, so you start getting into producing and you just figure what, I'm just gonna be a producer forever and this is? I didn't know. I thought I was just gonna be a producer for a minute.
是的，不，不，他们没有联系我。我知道，因为当时它归派拉蒙和ABC所有。对，所以你，对，对。所以你做那个，所以你开始进入制作领域，你只是想，我永远都要做制片人，这就是？我不知道。我以为我只会做一会儿制片人。
Yeah. And then it became a profession. And then we did sightings for seven years, studying all things paranormal. Wow. And then we did a wonderful show which was a kid show in So Weird. We produced it in Vancouver. Yeah. About a little girl, Mackenzie Phillips. This was her first job after cleaning herself up. And she was a rock star on a bus.
是的。然后它变成了一种职业。然后我们做了七年的《目击》，研究所有超自然事物。哇。然后我们做了一个很棒的节目，是一个儿童节目《如此怪异》。我们在温哥华制作的。是的。关于一个小女孩，麦肯齐·菲利普斯。这是她戒毒后的第一份工作。她是一个在巴士上的摇滚明星。
Oh, yes. Her manager drove the bus. Her daughter and the manager's son would go off when they were setting up the concerts and stuff and find paranormal experiences in whatever town they were in. It was called So Weird. All right, now how long did that one go?
哦，是的。她的经纪人开着巴士。当他们在布置音乐会之类的东西时，她的女儿和经纪人的儿子会跑出去，在他们所在的任何城镇寻找超自然体验。它叫《如此怪异》。好吧，那部剧播了多久？
That sounds like a sprint. That one went for three or four years. Three or four years out of that one, good Lord. All right, so then you're feeling buoyed by the producing success. There is still a passion for acting. Passion for acting, feeling horrible, that there's nothing.
听起来像是一场短跑。那部剧播了三四年。那部剧播了三四年，天哪。好吧，所以你因为制作上的成功而感到振奋。仍然对表演有热情。对表演有热情，感觉很糟糕，因为什么都没有。
Well because you were so, I mean you may have started the term typecast because you were so identifiable as the Fonz because he was so, so popular. I mean, listener, this was at a time when there were three networks, period. And Happy Days was, if not the top show, one of the top shows, you're probably getting 30 to 40 to 50 million people watching it every week.
嗯，因为你太……我的意思是，你可能开启了“类型化”这个词，因为你作为方兹太容易被识别了，因为他太、太受欢迎了。我的意思是，听众们，那是在只有三个电视网的时代。而《欢乐时光》是，如果不是顶级节目，也是顶级节目之一，你每周可能有3000万到4000万甚至5000万观众在看它。
You can't move, you can't ask an audience to see you as anything different because you're so beloved as that character, so to ask someone to hire you to play somebody else is probably a tall order. So you diversify into producing, you're doing the directing. At what point did you feel that maybe there'd been enough time now where you could start to have a realistic expectation to be hired as an actor?
你无法动弹，你无法要求观众把你视为不同的人，因为你作为那个角色太受爱戴了，所以要求别人雇你去演别人可能是一个很高的要求。所以你多元化发展到制作，你在做导演。在什么时刻你觉得现在可能已经有足够的时间，你可以开始对被雇佣为演员有现实的期望了？
Do you know what I learned? And I've used this image a lot, but I see myself as that toy with sand at the bottom. And you blow it up and it was a cowboy at one time, probably now it's a Star Wars figure, and you punch it, and it goes down, and it comes right back to center. I saw myself like that, that I would,
你知道我学到了什么吗？我经常使用这个形象，但我把自己看作那个底部有沙子的玩具。你把它吹起来，它曾经是一个牛仔，现在可能是一个星球大战人物，你打它，它倒下去，然后又回到中心。我把自己看作那样，我会，
and then eventually, what I learned is, for everybody who is listening, a lot of people will say no But you just stay at the table long enough Somebody is going to say yes right and I did a movie for television a real story about a father of two his wife was in an accident she was pregnant and of two, his wife was in an accident, she was pregnant, and I could have an abortion and keep the child, or she would have the child and I would lose my wife.
然后最终，我学到的是，对于每一个正在听的人，很多人会说不，但只要你在桌边待得足够久，总会有人说是的，对吧？我拍了一部电视电影，一个关于两个孩子的父亲的真实故事，他的妻子出了事故，她怀孕了，两个孩子的父亲，他的妻子出了事故，她怀孕了，我可以堕胎并保住孩子，或者她会生下孩子，而我会失去我的妻子。
Right. You know, and the right to lifers took me to the Supreme Court not to save my wife. Okay. Wow. I mean, that was the story, and we lived on Long Island. Yeah.
对。你知道，那些“生命权”支持者把我告上了最高法院，而不是为了救我的妻子。好吧。哇。我的意思是，那是故事，我们住在长岛。是的。
And you got some good responses from that, and it was a bit of a reset button for you? It was sort of a reset button, yes. And then I did one of the worst movies made by a human being called Control Tower, and on that set, I got a phone call, would I like to be in the water boy? Right, yeah, that's right.
你从那部电影中得到了一些好的回应，这对你来说是一个重置按钮吗？这算是一个重置按钮，是的。然后我拍了人类有史以来最糟糕的电影之一，叫《控制塔》，在那部电影的片场，我接到了一个电话，问我是否想出演《呆呆向前冲》。对，是的，没错。
Nice, and then, and let's get to one of my favorite shows of all time, Sean, it's called The Rest of Development, and you played a character on that. Let me write it down. You had, so you knew Jeffrey when you came on the show that. Let me write it down. So you knew Jeffrey when you came on the show. Yeah, a little bit. Did you know Mitch Hurwitz at all before you came?
不错，然后，让我们谈谈我最喜欢的节目之一，肖恩，它叫《发展受阻》，你在里面演了一个角色。让我写下来。你有，所以你来节目时认识杰弗里。让我写下来。所以你来节目时认识杰弗里。是的，一点点。你在来之前认识米奇·赫维茨吗？
I didn't know anybody and remember I was hired as your family lawyer for one or two episodes and happily stayed for the next five or six years. The name of the character was? Barry Zuckerkorn. Barry Zuckerkorn. Barry Zuckerkorn. Sean, there's a moment in season two of Arrest Development
我谁也不认识，记住我被雇为你们的家庭律师，演了一两集，然后很高兴地留下来演了接下来的五六年。那个角色的名字是？巴里·扎克康。巴里·扎克康。巴里·扎克康。肖恩，在《发展受阻》第二季有一个时刻，
where we're all out on the dock, we're supposed to be Orange County, but we're in the marina and we had, the show got sponsored, we were looking, we were hanging on by a thread, because the ratings weren't good, and we got a sponsor and it was like the, it was. Burger King. Burger King.
我们都在码头上，本应该是奥兰治县，但我们在码头，我们有，节目得到了赞助，我们正在看，我们悬在一线，因为收视率不好，我们得到了一个赞助商，它是……汉堡王。汉堡王。
Crispy sandwich or something, right? Oh God, I'm in, I'm in. So, you know, the term jumping the shark, of course, came from Henry when he was on Happy Days, when the Fonz jumps the shark, right? And then the criticism was, it was an episode so late in the run of the series that that they had basically run out of ideas and now
脆皮三明治之类的，对吧？哦天哪，我进去了，我进去了。所以，你知道，“跳过鲨鱼”这个词，当然，来自亨利在《欢乐时光》的时候，当方兹跳过鲨鱼时，对吧？然后批评是，那是剧集后期的一集，他们基本上已经没主意了，现在
They're gonna write that the Fonz jumps his motorcycle over a shark and you know, oh my god Aren't they reaching for storylines? So yeah, you know became known as you know, well, you know, you don't want to write that episode That's like jumping the shark. Except we were number one for the next four years. But they were number one, exactly. But the cynics sort of painted it that way and the term became jumping the shark.
他们要写方兹骑着摩托车跳过鲨鱼，你知道，哦天哪，他们不是在强行编剧情吗？所以，你知道，变成了众所周知的，你知道，好吧，你知道，你不想写那一集，那就像“跳过鲨鱼”。除了我们在接下来的四年里都是第一名。但他们是第一名，没错。但愤世嫉俗者以那种方式描绘它，这个词就变成了“跳过鲨鱼”。
So in this episode, in this moment where we're trying to figure out what we're gonna do and we've got this sponsor, we have to work in Burger King Chicken Sandwich in it. We have to actually have it in an episode. The Fox Network says, yeah, the only way we can cash in the money from Burger King is we've got to get the name of the sandwich into the actual dialogue of the show
所以在那一集里，在这个我们试图弄清楚我们要做什么的时刻，我们有了这个赞助商，我们必须把汉堡王的鸡肉三明治加进去。我们必须在剧集中实际拥有它。福克斯电视网说，是的，我们从汉堡王那里拿到钱的唯一方法就是我们必须把三明治的名字放进节目的实际对话中，
and we're just furious on set. And everybody's furious, and Mitch is furious. So if Mitch figures out this way, there's a scene where Henry's, now his character, Barry's like, talking to us about something and there are all these. Well Buster had just had his arm bitten off by a seal. By a seal. Out in the ocean.
我们在片场简直气疯了。每个人都很愤怒，米奇也很愤怒。所以如果米奇想出了这个方法，有一场戏是亨利，现在他的角色，巴里，在跟我们谈论某事，有所有这些……嗯，巴斯特刚被海豹咬掉了手臂。被海豹。在海洋里。
And then they captured, I guess what, the shark, no then they had a bunch of sharks on the thing and so Henry goes, listen, I'd love to talk to you guys about this but I gotta go to Burger King and get one of their crispy chicken sandwiches and then he just does a gingerly little hop over a shark Yeah, so good and the only actor in the universe who's jumped the shark twice that's right So Henry what what that's hysterical what it what excites you now you still get up and like I love acting
然后他们抓住了，我猜是什么，鲨鱼，不，然后他们在那个东西上有一堆鲨鱼，所以亨利说，听着，我很想和你们谈谈这个，但我得去汉堡王买他们的脆皮鸡肉三明治，然后他只是轻轻地跳过了一条鲨鱼。是的，太棒了，宇宙中唯一跳过两次鲨鱼的演员。没错。所以亨利，什么，什么，这太搞笑了，现在什么让你兴奋？你仍然起床，就像我喜欢表演，
I'm gonna keep acting till the day I die like yeah, I do love it. Yeah, that's good. I do I Have to say I'm in a moment in time right here as we're talking about Be very careful what you wish for Because my life, you know, I wrote a memoir last doctor. Yes, you did Called being Henry Henry. I love Life, you know, I wrote a memoir last October. Yes, you did. Yes. Called Being Henry. Being Henry. Being Henry, I love that.
我要一直演到死，像，是的，我确实喜欢它。是的，那很好。我确实，我不得不说，正如我们所谈论的，我正处于一个时刻，要非常小心你所祈求的，因为我的生活，你知道，我写了一本回忆录，去年。是的，你写了。叫《成为亨利》。亨利，我爱生活，你知道，我去年十月写了一本回忆录。是的，你写了。是的。叫《成为亨利》。《成为亨利》。《成为亨利》，我喜欢那个。
It is. So it was on the New York Times bestseller list. It was a New York Times bestseller for 11 weeks. 11 weeks. Wow. Then I went to Australia to tour with the book. And it became number one. And now they're taking me to Ireland, Scotland,
它是。所以它在《纽约时报》畅销书排行榜上。它在《纽约时报》畅销书排行榜上待了11周。11周。哇。然后我去了澳大利亚巡回宣传这本书。它变成了第一名。现在他们要带我去爱尔兰、苏格兰，
and England on a book tour. So, oh my goodness gracious me. That's so cool, congratulations. I can't forget, we have to mention Detective Duck, because the new one is coming out in October. The second one. The children's book. There are gonna be four. That's more my speed.
和英格兰进行图书巡回宣传。所以，哦，天哪。太酷了，恭喜。我不能忘记，我们必须提到《侦探鸭》，因为新的一本要在十月出来。第二本。儿童读物。会有四本。那更适合我的节奏。
Now, is this a Zipser? No, Hank Zipser was 28 in total. 28 books, seven million copies sold. 28 individual novels. Then we wrote Here's Hank when he was in the second grade. And Here's Hank, I'll tell you is really interesting because we use a font that has never been used before. Can you see?
现在，这是齐普瑟吗？不，汉克·齐普瑟总共有28本。28本书，售出700万册。28本独立小说。然后我们写了《这是汉克》，当他在二年级的时候。而《这是汉克》，我告诉你真的很有趣，因为我们使用了一种以前从未用过的字体。你能看见吗？
It makes it easier for the eye and the mind to connect. That's more spread apart. Wow. And a dad whose children were dyslexic developed it in Holland, the new font. And so that's a font and a style that dyslexics can read? It makes it so much easier, Sean, to actually read it.
它让眼睛和大脑更容易连接。那是更分散的。哇。一位孩子有阅读障碍的父亲在荷兰开发了它，这种新字体。所以这是一种阅读障碍者可以阅读的字体和风格？肖恩，它让阅读变得容易多了。
The words are weighted on the page because a lot of times, if you have a learning challenge, the words float or letters float or you have a learning challenge, the words float or letters float or you leave a word out, this allows you to anchor your eyes. Henry, it doesn't matter. You could put that book in a Big Mac and Sean's not going to read. Okay? So it doesn't matter what you do.
文字在页面上是有权重的，因为很多时候，如果你有学习障碍，文字会漂浮，或者字母会漂浮，或者你有学习障碍，文字会漂浮，或者字母会漂浮，或者你漏掉一个词，这让你能够锚定你的眼睛。亨利，没关系。你可以把那本书放在巨无霸里，肖恩也不会读。好吧？所以你做什么都没关系。
No, I'll eat it. But I just think it's so incredible that you've got the world famous dyslexia and yet you're one of the most world famous authors that there is. That happened? And that you're a graduate of Yale and you have learning disability. It's just, it's so incredible what you've done
不，我会吃掉它。但我只是觉得太不可思议了，你拥有世界闻名的阅读障碍，但你却是世界上最著名的作家之一。那发生了？而且你是耶鲁大学的毕业生，你有学习障碍。这真是太不可思议了，你所做的一切
with your life, the longevity of your career, your ability to maintain relevance. Barry, you find, was that your first Emmy award? That was my first Emmy. I won two daytime Emmys, but that was my first. Yeah, but I mean, having so much success for so long and you're actually still escalating, there's still a peak, you know, now at this age.
你的生活，你职业生涯的持久性，你保持相关性的能力。巴里，你发现，那是你的第一个艾美奖吗？那是我的第一个艾美奖。我赢得了两个日间艾美奖，但那是我的第一个。是的，但我的意思是，拥有这么长时间的成功，而且你实际上还在升级，在这个年龄，仍然有一个高峰，你知道。
So it's just so admirable what you have continued to do. Maintain doing. But I am, it's not lost on me that this is my incredible life. I'm not kidding. Yeah, I get your appreciation. Yeah, it is sincere. I'm a believer.
所以你继续做的事情真是令人钦佩。保持做。但我，我没有忘记这是我不可思议的生活。我不是在开玩笑。是的，我理解你的感激。是的，它是真诚的。我是个信徒。
I don't think you're faking it anymore. What's great is you come in, from my experience, you show up, you're the kind of guy, you show up every day on set, like it's a new opportunity, it's a new day, you bring great energy, you always, you wanna laugh, you wanna experience, you're very much in the moment at all times. You're one of those people, I love that about you.
我不认为你在假装了。最棒的是你进来，根据我的经验，你出现，你是那种人，你每天出现在片场，就像这是一个新的机会，这是一个新的一天，你带来巨大的能量，你总是，你想笑，你想体验，你总是非常专注于当下。你是那种人，我喜欢你这一点。
I really do. Well, you people, I love that about you. I really do. Well, you know, I'll tell you something. You dream about it, you're told, you will never achieve. Right. And then here I am in all these wonderful experiences. I'm overwhelmed. I'm over fucking well.
我真的喜欢。嗯，你们，我喜欢你这一点。我真的喜欢。嗯，你知道，我告诉你一件事。你梦想着它，有人告诉你，你永远不会实现。对。然后我在这里经历了所有这些美妙的经历。我不知所措。我他妈的不知所措。
Right, and I think when you lead with gratitude like you do, people are then drawn to you, and that's why you are a light that everybody loves and loves being around. And through all of this, you've managed to have one of the most successful marriages in show business, which is no easy thing. Oh, that's next Wednesday.
对，我认为当你像你一样以感恩为先时，人们就会被你吸引，这就是为什么你是一盏每个人都喜欢并喜欢与之相处的光。通过这一切，你成功地拥有了演艺界最成功的婚姻之一，这可不是一件容易的事。哦，那是下周三。
So, oh, he's done next Wednesday. Just to Wednesday. Oh, next Wednesday. So we're making news. Hey, listen, he's done next Wednesday. Just to Wednesday. Next Wednesday. So we're making news. Hey, listen, you had a good run. Bye, Stacey. You had a good run. But the kids are happy, you know, like, you know.
所以，哦，他下周三就完了。只是到周三。哦，下周三。所以我们在制造新闻。嘿，听着，他下周三就完了。只是到周三。下周三。所以我们在制造新闻。嘿，听着，你度过了一段美好的时光。再见，斯泰西。你度过了一段美好的时光。但孩子们很高兴，你知道，你知道。
She's not gonna hear this, is she? No, no, she'll never hear this. No, no, no, no, no. She's in another room. I could say anything I want. Yeah, but I'm crazy about Max and Zoe. I don't know Jed, I don't think. I don't think I've met Jed.
她不会听到这个，会吗？不，不，她永远不会听到这个。不，不，不，不，不。她在另一个房间。我可以随心所欲地说任何话。是的，但我对马克斯和佐伊很着迷。我不认识杰德，我不认为。我不认为我见过杰德。
Jed's great. I know Jed, as you know, I know Jed very well. Yeah. I don't know Jed. I don't think. I don't think I've met Jed. You know, Jed's great. I know Jed. As you know, I know Jed very well. Yeah, he's a great dude. It was a promise I made to Stacey. I never wanted to duplicate parenthood the way I experienced it. I'm just telling you that's true.
杰德很棒。我认识杰德，如你所知，我非常了解杰德。是的。我不认识杰德。我不认为。我不认为我见过杰德。你知道，杰德很棒。我认识杰德。如你所知，我非常了解杰德。是的，他是个很棒的家伙。这是我给斯泰西的承诺。我从来不想以我经历过的方式复制为人父母。我只是告诉你那是真的。
And I made a promise that I would be a different father. And the lesson I learned there is a heard child is a powerful child. If they believe you're just listening, that they exist, it just helps them fly to the sun. You know, that's your next book, Parenting, a book about parenting. You should.
我承诺我会成为一个不同的父亲。我学到的教训是，一个被倾听的孩子是一个强大的孩子。如果他们相信你只是在倾听，他们存在，这只会帮助他们飞向太阳。你知道，那是你的下一本书，育儿，一本关于育儿的书。你应该。
You got those good advice at the beginning when you were talking about the kids and stuff, your kids. I'll buy it and read it. Henry, we love you. We do love you. I love you. You've given us 60 minutes of your valuable life and we really, really appreciate it.
你在刚开始谈论孩子之类的事情时，你的孩子，你得到了那些好的建议。我会买它并读它。亨利，我们爱你。我们确实爱你。我爱你。你给了我们60分钟你宝贵的生命，我们真的，真的非常感激。
Please hug and kiss your entire family. I'm so happy that you invited me. It's long overdue. Each one of you individually is very important to me. Who's your favorite? My favorite? Who's your favorite? Of these three? Just tell me tell me, just tell me.
请拥抱并亲吻你的整个家庭。我很高兴你邀请我。这早就该做了。你们每个人对我来说都很重要。谁是你的最爱？我的最爱？谁是你的最爱？这三个人里？告诉我，告诉我，告诉我。
Okay, I'm writing it down. Okay, okay. Don't you misspell my name, God damn it. Yeah. We love you so, so much. We love you, Henry. I can't wait to come over for another yummy dinner. Continued success, you're the best.
好吧，我把它写下来。好吧，好吧。别拼错我的名字，该死的。是的。我们非常非常爱你。我们爱你，亨利。我迫不及待地想再去吃一顿美味的晚餐。继续成功，你是最棒的。
Just remember, there is a seat at our table for each one of you. I'm coming over. And Sean, your hubby. I know, I have to, I'm coming. Okay. I would love that. You gotta do it.
记住，我们的餐桌上为你们每个人留了一个位置。我要过来了。还有肖恩，你的丈夫。我知道，我必须，我要来了。好吧。我会喜欢的。你必须这样做。
It's gonna have to be waffles and tuna fish, right? Yeah, exactly. Together again. Is that all you eat? Pretty much. No, he'll eat anything. Henry, send our love to your whole family, to all the kids, to everybody. We love you guys.
那得是华夫饼和金枪鱼，对吧？是的，完全正确。再次在一起。你只吃那个吗？差不多。不，他什么都吃。亨利，向你的全家，向所有的孩子，向每个人传达我们的爱。我们爱你们。
Love you. You know what? When you were here at our table and we had scooped bagels with melted cheese, they don't make that cheese anymore. No kidding. No. Altadena stopped making that cheese
爱你。你知道吗？当你在这里坐在我们的餐桌旁，我们有融化奶酪的勺子百吉饼，他们不再做那种奶酪了。不开玩笑。不。阿尔塔迪纳停止生产那种奶酪了
and it's never been the same. Listen, Altadena, if you're listening, if you work at Altadena right now, the Fonz wants you to start making that fucking cheese again Yeah, listen up. Yeah, so a white cheddar All right Henry, I love you enjoy the rest of your day, thank you my best at home everybody, okay Bye pal. Bye. Oh If you guys got your act together,
而且再也没有那种味道了。听着，阿尔塔迪纳，如果你在听，如果你现在在阿尔塔迪纳工作，方兹希望你开始再次生产那种该死的奶酪。是的，听着。是的，所以白切达。好吧，亨利，我爱你，享受你剩下的一天，谢谢。祝家里每个人都好，好吗？再见，伙计。再见。哦，如果你们能把自己的行为整理好，
you might be able to live as successful and as warm and as nice a life as he has, okay? Yeah. Why don't you just, you know, just mind it, okay? But the gratitude thing is big. I remember walking down the street in Beverly Hills or West Hollywood or something, and there was a deli, I was walking into a deli,
你们也许能过上像他一样成功、温暖和美好的生活，好吗？是的。你为什么不，你知道，只是注意一下，好吗？但感恩这件事很重要。我记得走在比佛利山庄或西好莱坞的街上，有一家熟食店，我正走进一家熟食店，
and he was walking out, and he's, and that's how I know it's all real because he's exactly how he is in life as he was when we were just talking to him. He's like that with anybody. It doesn't matter who you are or what you do, he's interested in what you do. He's constantly talking to people. I mean for 50 years he's been a fucking icon.
他正走出来，这就是我知道这一切都是真实的原因，因为他在生活中就像我们刚才和他交谈时一样。他对任何人都是那样。无论你是谁，无论你做什么，他都对你所做的事情感兴趣。他一直在和人交谈。我的意思是，50年来他一直是一个该死的偶像。
That's what happy looks like. Yeah but it's surprising though because he's so recognizable, you would think that somebody like him had developed an ability, maybe even a habit, of seeming somewhat standoffish so that people didn't approach him. But instead, he's absolutely the opposite.
这就是快乐的样子。是的，但这很令人惊讶，因为他太容易被认出来了，你会认为像他这样的人已经发展出一种能力，甚至是一种习惯，显得有些冷漠，这样人们就不会接近他。但相反，他绝对是相反的。
It's remarkable. It's amazing he was self-aware enough to be grateful about that success so early on. Yeah, and then he found arguably even bigger success with Barry here almost 50 years later. And all the books that he wrote, what do you wanna do to those books? Do you wanna get them?
这太了不起了。令人惊叹的是，他那么早就有了自我意识，能对那样的成功心存感激。是的，而且近50年后，他凭借《巴瑞》获得了可以说更大的成功。他写的所有那些书，你想怎么处理？你想得到它们吗？
Do you wanna lease them? What do you wanna do? Do you wanna rent them? Or do you wanna buy the bugs? Or you want to buy them? Are you late for something? Do you have to go somewhere? What are you doing? See, I was going to do, instead of an ay, I was going to do a bye.
你想租赁它们吗？你想做什么？你想租用它们吗？还是你想买这些书？或者你想买下它们？你是有什么急事吗？你得去哪儿吗？你在干什么？你看，我本来想说的是“再见”，而不是“哎”。
Oh, no. You guys are flying home today, huh? Yeah, we're on the same flight. Oh, that's Sean. You're on it. All right. We're on the same flight. Love you both so much and an official bye Smart list is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarff.
哦，不。你们今天飞回家，对吧？是的，我们搭同一班飞机。哦，那是肖恩。你也在那班飞机上。好的。我们搭同一班飞机。非常爱你们俩，官方的“再见”SmartList是由Bennett Barbico、Michael Grant Terry和Rob Armjarff百分之百有机且手工制作的。
If you like SmartList, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey. Hey, it's Guy Raz here, the host of How I Built This, a podcast that gives you a front row seat to how some of the biggest products were built and the innovators, entrepreneurs, and idealists behind them. Every week I speak to someone new. Stories like Justin Wolverton's, a lawyer who just wanted a healthy alternative to ice
如果你喜欢SmartList，现在就可以通过在Wondery应用程序或Apple Podcasts上加入Wondery Plus来提前收听无广告版本。在离开之前，请在Wondery.com/survey填写一份简短的调查问卷，告诉我们关于你的信息。嘿，我是Guy Raz，《How I Built This》的主持人，这是一个让你近距离了解一些最伟大的产品是如何打造的，以及它们背后的创新者、企业家和理想主义者的播客。每周我都会采访一个新人。比如Justin Wolverton的故事，他是一名律师，只是想要一种健康的冰淇淋替代品
cream, so he created Halo Top in his Cuisinart. Or Todd Graves, who grew his fried chicken restaurant Raising Canes into one of the most successful fast food chains in the US. All of these great conversations can help you learn how to think big, take risks, and navigate crises in life and work from people who've done all of that and more. Follow How I Built This on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to How I Built This early and ad free right now on Wondery Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以他用他的Cuisinart料理机创造了Halo Top。或者Todd Graves，他将他的炸鸡餐厅Raising Canes发展成了美国最成功的快餐连锁店之一。所有这些精彩的对话都能帮助你学习如何从那些已经做到这一切甚至更多的人身上去思考大局、承担风险并应对生活和工作中的危机。在Wondery应用程序或你获取播客的任何地方关注《How I Built This》。你现在就可以在Wondery Plus上提前收听无广告的《How I Built This》。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。